last week i asked our fans to help me
figure out
what snack joe biden looks like this is
important
it's very important i mean there's a lot
going on but this is important yes
thank you we all know donald trump looks
like an orange
cheeto and people have been making
orange cheeto jokes
for a long time and we can agree on that
that was never in contention
a divided country but everyone agreed
donald trump looks like an orange cheeto
and that comparison has served late
night comedians very well
but now we're moving on and that begs
the question
what snack does joe biden look like yeah
we need to know how to make fun of him
exactly and the only way to make fun of
a president is by knowing what snack he
looks like
exactly it's the only way trust me
we're professionals and we've looked
into it anywho
last week i told our fans to go to
teamcoco.com and vote on which snacks
joe biden looked like the most
now we gave him five choices yogurt
covered raisin
pirate booty japanese shrimp chip cotton
candy
and saltine there was also a place to
write in your answers
a lot of people wrote in frosted mini
wheat which
yeah you can see that it's not bad
that's not bad we also got plenty of
marshmallow and nillow wafers yeah
but there was a clear winner
and we're going to announce that winner
right now we had a total of over
4 000 votes and the winner by far
with over 1 300 votes was
and this is not a contested election
this is a clear victory are you ready
andy
yes okay here we go the snack joe biden
looks the most like according to you the
viewer
japanese shrimp chip whoa
yeah incredible
wow yeah so now we know joe biden
officially looks like
a shrimp chip and now that we know that
we can start working that into some
jokes
oh that's good yeah that's the idea yeah
joe biden announcing his goals for the
first term
biden has promised to give americans
affordable health care student loan debt
relief and satisfying salty crunch
because of the shrimp chip thing yeah
check this one out
michael b jordan was just named people's
sexiest man alive
meanwhile joe biden was named crunchiest
sake bar snack alive
the glasses the glasses thing that could
be your thing
hey hey i got to ask you andy
i'm here what's the difference between
joe biden and a japanese shrimp chip
uh i don't know conan people are happy
when you bring chips to a party
they're not happy when you bring biden
why
because he's the president he looks like
a he's bland
all right i mean it's not safe for him
to be out at a party i mean really
no one should be in a journey that's the
joke the joke is
people if you bring him to the party
they're worried he's gonna get covered
and they're so happy he's the new
president right so they'd rather
um a chip
i guess like you could you could call it
just you and a bowl of shrimp chips you
could call that a party
and it would be safe yeah but if joe
biden came to your house
and it was a gathering of people odds
are
there's going to be you know spittle
a lot of laughter could be a super
spreader
certainly a lot of talk that's all true
but what does that have to do with the
shrimp chip
it has nothing to do with the shrimp
chip it's just about i hope joe biden
stays healthy
i forget why were we talking about i
don't even know
ah thanks a lot america
i think japanese shrimp chip i think
that was our best
contest ever you know what i don't think
it was our best contest ever i think it
was
the best contest ever in human history
and that includes all the olympics in
all time including ancient greece